oh taking the boss ladies on the wall
path this morning every morning
no ding dong ding dong
i really think i could help this company
if you just gave me a chance
just concentrate on being my assistant
were you always mean
i got big and i got rich so now who
gonna check me boo i wish you were my
age then i'd check you
boo i wish you
were little i told you watch it
[Music]
i'm so excited to sit down with the
ladies of little first of all the
trailer did you guys feel the love
because the minute that trailer went out
we were just like
rolling with laughter so what were your
reactions i was really amazed that the
love of treason yeah
like wow people are people are into it
and then it made me realize like oh this
is the first time
in a very long time i want to say since
qriklin
oh and then we had a wrinkle in time but
like a little black girl lead
not that you're a little black girl yeah
that's how good i get i understand
young black girl young black girl young
lady black girl i mean and also a boss i
mean regina and marseille like first of
all
did you ladies feel it on set being like
ep now you got a first
look deal did y'all feel that because i
was like i have life choices that i must
have messed up
i was only concerned about barbies and
boys
so did y'all were y'all like okay she's
our boss but you know
also the fourteenth is this one is so
smart
thank you so incredibly like
just wise and professional beyond her
years
like once you know her then i think
you're not surprised
yeah you're not surprised at all and
she's also still a kid it's not yeah
yeah yeah
i mean i still like boys and i still
like all these other
teenage regular stuff so it's i'm still
missing but she still feels like
not fast
yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's good well
you did have some fast moments in this
because
embodying your character you got to
flirt with justin hartley which is like
anyone who's watched this is us
has wanted to flirt with him so what was
it like doing the little flirt with him
uh throughout the movie i mean when i
saw the script i was thinking like
who could this be you know i was like ah
and then i actually looked at like who
was gonna be i was like
oh okay but working with justin you
didn't make it weird at all
i thought it was weird because it could
be weird it was the first day because
that was like the first day of me being
in atlanta we were just
doing our stuff and that was the first
day of us working on set so i was like
okay this is a great first scene i mean
i'm flirting with you that's awesome
you know um but but no he didn't make it
weird at all so
it was lots of fun working with him
that's good and then regina you're
teaming with will packer you guys have
such
a great relationship and then coming on
to this i think it was lena that just
talked about we're in a black
renaissance right now with like films
and movies but
this one is such a fun comedy like what
are you looking forward to between girls
tripping this like the future of you
know black comedy just having a whole
resurgence i think
i mean i just think it's exciting it's
an exciting time it's a great time
there's so many amazing women to work
with
um i love this one we've got to work
together briefly in blackish but to be
able to support her
in this issa and i have wanted to work
together forever so to be able
to work with people whose work i admire
women whose work ethic i admire
you know what i mean and to see that
there's you know will who's
putting that together and you know
creating you know the space
uh for us to do that it's really i mean
i think it's amazing and i
it's exciting because i get to see what
more is gonna come from
myself and and the women i work with i
mean east is always doing something
amazing and so i just think
all the work individually and then what
we will be able to collaborate
with will be you know even more exciting
yeah
and then issa on this one i love because
your characters deal with like this was
great women on this set but that's a bad
woman dynamic and so did you think did
you think back to your
bad bosses maybe some some slight you
know devil or prada's moment for you
yeah i did i thought back to i tried to
think back to bad bosses but then i was
like i was a bad employee
like i wasn't the best i was the one
like mad that i couldn't work on a
script
when i was supposed to be at work and i
think about like
i did have one bad boss but i went and
thinking about it i was like if i were
her i would i would have fired me so
quickly i would have been so annoyed
by me so um it just made me realize how
to be a better worker because april in
the movie really just needs to speak up
um even though her boss is terrible and
doesn't listen to her ideas she needs a
backbone
as well that's a good one and then
jordan we learn like there's reasons
behind why jordan
is the way that she is throughout the
film but you got to embrace your inner
mean girl because i always think of you
as like nice characters
so sweet like support the girls you're
just you're like everyone's mom and in
this one
you were so not nice did you like
embracing your inner
yeah it was fun i mean it's fun because
you know in real life
you would never behave that way so like
for con
but you know for comedy it really was
fun like
you know and it's really fun because you
know for me it's hard to not laugh at
their reactions
because you have to see people reacting
to you being a monster
um but yeah no it was fun it was it was
i have to say i
i did enjoy it and you enjoyed it right
yes i enjoyed it a lot
so just a couple more before uh regina
and issa you guys are like maybe five
years older than marseille so
if you think back thank you so much for
that
that time is there something that you
really missed from being
you know 13 14. no
i hated that it's funny okay like being
nostalgic now there's things that i
would do differently
the music the the time
the carefreeness non-obligation
no bills you still found stuff to
complain about
but it was being 14 was rough
just because there's just so much drama
like even you were talking about earlier
like drama with your friends it
doesn't doesn't even matter in the long
run but
the music i miss a lot did you miss
anything i loved 14.
okay i had my friends at school i had
like
but like everybody wanted to be your
friend yeah i was i was a tomboy
you know what i mean i had my brothers
that's what i really miss i miss
i miss the relationship that you have
with your siblings
when y'all are just around the house
creating havoc for your parents
and you don't know it it's like there's
something in that time that's like
when i look back like those times are
creating who i am today you know what i
mean so
i think i missed just the dynamics of
like
there was a simplicity that i missed
that was you know
i ain't it was oh my goodness my first
crush
oh you have 14. yeah
i was a late bloomer i was well they're
wrapping people real quick mark say what
are you looking forward to like
you've already done like half the things
i would have wanted to do still
wasn't even thinking about bad about
asking you but what are you looking
forward to um
i get there yeah well five years older
yeah like five years older you know
i mean i'm really looking forward to
driving but i drive this year so
i'm wanting to like be a professional
better driver
um hopefully by that time i'll have like
i'll be able to retire by the time i'm
like 25
maybe not but we'll figure it out but um
yeah i mean is it fun is it fun right
now it's the most fun i've had in my
life
okay then i'm looking forward to it then
yeah
you